Speaker 1: We have been following over the last
48 hours a rush to virtue signal by Republicans
about the United States border with Mexico.
Even governors, senators, members of Congress
from landlocked non border states are jumping in
on the bandwagon. Why? Well, because as Joni Ernst
said in a video, which we'll look at in a moment.
Every state is now a border state. They're first
of all. We have to understand at the top level
what's going on here. Very little has changed
under the Biden administration since the
Trump administration as far as immigration
goes. What has changed well as the pandemic
has eased, depending on how you look at it.
Mobility has really increased. And a lot of the
pent up demand from 2020 of folks who did not move
physically is now ramping up. That is responsible
for part of the increase we are seeing, and folks
trying to cross seasonality plays a role. We all
we talked about that in the spring. In the spring,
seasonality plays a role compared to winter months
under Trump that are the basis for comparison,
but very little has actually changed. The
Haitian situation has not been particularly
dealt with by Joe Biden, but that that's
we don't think it's been dealt with well
in a different way than Republicans.
Don't think it's been dealt with well.
But Republicans want to make it seem as though
Joe Biden has opened the border and is saying,
come on in to whoever the hell wants to come in
and I'm going to play some clips for you here of
a variety of different Republicans jumping in on
the action here is Senator Joni Ernst. She's from
Iowa, Iowa, a landlocked state nowhere near the
u.s.-mexico border. Listen to what she had to say.
Speaker 2: The reality is that every state is
now a border state. Hmm. All of the issues that
are affecting Texas and those that are saying this
sweep of illegals coming across the border, all of
those issues are now facing every other state.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So the argument that they are
making is people might come in through a border
state, but then they use extremely dehumanizing
language like animals, cockroaches. They just
spread into all these different states. This is
the just this is the imagery. She goes on to
go full Trump in her fear mongering, talking
about rapists. That's just they love talking
about rapists when they talk about the border
Speaker 2: with an extraordinary number of
people crossing the border illegally. Of course,
we are going to have rapists. We're going to
have those that are terrorists, we're going
to have other bad people. And all right.
Speaker 1: So if that vocabulary sounds
familiar to you, it should, because it's
the exact same vocabulary vocabulary
with which Donald Trump opened as 2016 Republican
primary campaign for president really in 2015 is
when he actually started it. Then we go, This one
is just amazing. Ted Cruz puts on a performance.
There was a shooting yesterday in Texas, and Ted
Cruz has one of these incredible performances
where he does his sort of like fake, genuine,
very somber. And then. It's directly from the
school shooting to just go after Joe Biden for
the border. It's just it's weirdly jarring.
Speaker 3: And there have been far too many
of these at far too many schools. And so we
are grateful for the courage and the heroism, the
first responders. And we are hopeful that that all
of the students or individuals who may have been
injured will will come through and survive. Right.
We're here today because
of the Biden border crisis
that continues to rage on the southern
border. Yeah. All right. So we're
driving in there to hear a little bit.
Speaker 1: What a transition, folks. What
a transition and a very similar dynamic actually
down at the border. Republican Texas Governor Greg
Abbott went to went down to the border. They set
up an entire dog and pony show with. You can see
in the background if you're watching, I see a
chopper, two tanks, I think armored vehicles of
different kinds. And in this clip, you're going
to hear Greg Abbott talk about the influx of
migrants at the southern border. Take a listen.
Speaker 4: This is one of, if not the most urgent
matter that we're facing in the United States
at this time, and it's time for the Biden
administration to wake up and get on the job and
do its job to protect the sovereignty and safety
of the United States of America. Now, remember,
Speaker 1: very little has changed. This urgency
is a very concocted, fabricated, essentially
out of thin air. What changed? A Democrat in
the White House? That's what changed that. We
have had an ebb and flow on this issue. We have
no permanent status for DOCA recipients. We have
not done all sorts of other types of reform that
have been discussed for a very long time, and
this is a virtue signaling a party that they
are essentially throwing for themselves. Greg
Abbott was actually just to kind of close the
loop on the school shooting as well. Greg Abbott
was asked about the school shooter, and he said,
Listen, this is not about gun control because the
school shooter possessed the gun illegally anyway.
Governor, are you concerned
that the law unconstitutional,
Unidentified: sending the wrong message
to young people and that we could?
Speaker 4: So very importantly, with regard to the
school shooting that took place today, as well as
with really any school shooting that I'm aware
of, the gun that was possessed by the shooter
was possessed illegally and we will make
sure that laws are enforced and those who
act illegally will be held accountable.
Speaker 1: So listen, first of all,
I'm almost positive that we not long ago
we have so many school shootings in this
country. It's hard to keep track,
but I'm pretty sure that under the
Trump administration, I'm not blaming Trump. I'm
just saying during the time Trump was president,
there was a school shooting where the guns were
legally owned, although maybe that was the one
in California at the Bart station. There are so
many shootings in the United States that it's
difficult to keep track of. But the point is,
they always go. They go, Listen, the laws don't
matter because the shooters will just get the guns
illegally. But as we've said many times before,
if you have more uniform laws, you make it more
difficult to just go to the neighboring place to
get the guns illegally because there are simply
fewer guns around. At some point, the illegal gun
was a legal gun and then something happened. You
know, they like to say, Well, if guns are stolen,
that's no one's fault. But of course, we know
there are many other ways that these guns
ultimately end up in the hands of people who do
wrong with them. So on the shooting, the normal
stuff we would expect. But this border craze, they
all of a sudden have Fox News with the Kyron's and
the lower thirds about panic, panic, panic at
the border. Remember that very modest changes
in terms of circumstances from Trump to Biden.
But what's changed is Biden's a Democrat. Trump
was a Republican, and now Republicans want to
talk about this. Let me know your thoughts. You
can find me on Twitter at De Packman and remember
that on Tuesday, October 19, we are doing a live
viewer town hall at 6:00 p.m. Eastern. It will be
streamed live only on the second YouTube channel,
Pacman Live. Find it at youtube.com slash Pacman
Live and six p.m. Eastern it Tuesday, October 19